in a world of big Libs like Taylor Swift
and strong deeply right-wing
conservatives like Lana Del re where
does Miley Cyrus figure in I've always
had a soft spot for Miley ever since
Party in the USA I've had a little bit
of a soft spot for Miley I don't listen
really to any modern music but Miley has
a new song it's called used to be young
10 million views in just three days
number two trending on YouTube music I
will bring all of my analytical skills
to bear as a Miley
fan head I don't know what a Miley fan
is called to analyze this song truth
there bulletproof there's no falling you
I don't dress the
same me and to you say hours yesterday
have gone all separate
ways left my living fast somewhere in
the best cuz that's for Chasing
Cars turns out open bars Le to broken
Hearts I'm going way too
far I know I used to be crazy I know I
used to be fun you say I Used to Be Wild
I say I used to be young you tell me
Thomas don't change me that's fine I
better a good run I know I used to be
crazy that's cuz I used to be young put
a pause there I really like this already
I really like the lyrics I like the she
walks out the first thing she says is
the truth is bulletproof there's no
fooling you I don't dress the same and
she's wearing what would be one of her
sexy like sequined red thing low cut
kind of dresses but she's got this
Mickey Mouse t-shirt on top of it so
you're not you're not seeing any
cleavage it's actually quite modest
albeit a little bit weird who do you
work for Dream works there's a an irony
to it which is she said saying you're
saying I used to be crazy and I used to
be fun well I'm saying I used to be
young and now I'm moving out of that so
the the red dress the sultry dress is
supposed to represent when she was young
and the new clothing is to represent
that she's now moved on to a more mature
stage in her life but the addition of
the clothing is something that she would
have worn as a child it's a Mickey Mouse
t-shirt so the irony of that is too
mature to grow past a a reckless wild
rebellious phase one act
returns in a way to one's childhood one
recovers one's innocence and that's not
a regression that's actually a process
of maturity that's a really subtle point
in it's obviously intentional you know
the Mickey Mouse shirt was was a
decision that someone made that's a an
insightful point about growing up and
then she says look I used to be crazy I
used to be fun I Used to Be Wild but yes
I'm saying I used to just be young so
it's not that my personality is
radically changed it's that I'm
accepting that I'm growing older and
maturing if you're a degenerate the way
you could read that is okay well I
shouldn't have any regrets about my past
about what I did when I was young you're
talking to me man cuz that's just when I
was young and that was appropriate to
being young but now I'm just in a
different phase and so no big deal but
the song seems to be full of regret you
see I mean her eye her eyes are
glistening with tears so it it's clear
that she has some regrets here to me I
used to be crazy it's not good to be
crazy that's irrational be crazy
open bars lead to broken hearts and
going way too far that's she's
expressing a regret no one desires a
broken heart so the deeper reading of
that is yeah I used to be young and
being young I did stupid things and now
I'm older and be unlike what a lot of
people would suggest in especially pop
music but but in our modern culture
generally is that getting old is bad we
don't want to get old we put on all
sorts of creams and have all sorts of
surgeries and we try to do our best to
look young for everything I'll make you
20 years Young she saying no no I'm
older now and it's I am better for being
older than I was when I was young the
other thing just knowing a little bit
about Miley Cyrus's career this would
seem to me to represent a new shift in
her career she did this famously she she
was a child star and she was on a
Nickelodeon show or Disney or something
like that and then when she decided to
become a sex icon she made a big splash
it was obviously a PR stunt and she
started doing all this outrageous kind
of behavior the same way Madonna did the
same way Britney did but now this would
seem to be a pretty direct and explicit
way of saying I'm moving into a new
phase of my career keep going take one
pour it
cry like tat and regrets words I never
met and want to Got
Away left my living fast somewhere in
the past and took another
road turns out prob wrong empty out soon
there else to
go I know I used to be crazy I know I
used to be fun you I Used to Be Wild I
say put a pause there so she goes take
one pour it out it's not worth crying
about the things you can't erase like
tattoos and regrets words I never meant
and ones that got away so again the
shallow read here is going to be have no
regrets whatever carpet DM YOLO but
she's not saying that she's saying no no
no pour one out for this sadness for
this bygone era and pour one out for for
my own sadness it's not worth crying
about I don't want to live in the past
forever I want to mature I want to move
on I've already come to the recognition
of my own mistakes and problems and sins
and I'm moving
on all the ones that Got Away I've just
I'm just leaving that in the past I'm
taking another
road cuz I'm not young anymore keep
going
I be crazy messed up for God was it fun
I know it used to be wild that's cuz I
used to be on those wasted nights and
always did I remember
everyone I know I used to be crazy
that's cuz I used to be young so this
last St is going to be the most open to
misinterpretation she goes I know I used
to be crazy messed up but God was it fun
and and so the shallow read on this
would be her reveling in the joys of her
past transgressions and sins and to some
degree people do that I talked about
Aristotle's four phases of virtue you
know they're they're the people who sin
all the time and love it really get a k
kick out of sinning then there are the
people who are incontinent so they know
that they should be doing the right
thing but they end up doing the wrong
thing because they just can't resist
their appetites then they're the people
who are continent so they know that they
should be doing the right thing and they
do the right thing but only grudgingly
it's really hard and they kind of want
to do the bad thing you know they want
to have another drink or go to the club
or whatever and then there are The
Virtuous people who who derive Joy from
doing the right thing and she's saying I
messed up but you know it was really fun
back then I think she's somewhere
between the latter two stages here
continence and virtue in in her
description of how she's feeling because
she's saying yeah it it was fun and
those nights are not wasted so like I
still remember that it it gave me some
pleasure and the nights were not wasted
why because she can enjoy them in her
mind you know no I think more because
she's learned lessons from them the
lessons that she's explained throughout
the entire song All That momentary
pleasure led to broken hearts and words
that I wish I didn't say and all sorts
of problems that were that made me crazy
and I'm no longer crazy as I remember
all those nights and you have to
remember those nights uh so that you
don't make the same mistakes yeah I used
to be young you say times changed me
yeah that's true I had a good run I used
to be crazy I used to be young now I'm
older what does that mean means I'm
serer and more rational
Miley it's good stuff I came in like a
what's a Miley fan called I don't know
I'm a Miley
head